so here's all we can conclude for this
and I can go through more and more
available than I want to okay five and a
half that's a square root of five
that's my a new definition my new way of
writing it's kind of like a concert
before 500 higher third is the cube root
of five
what would you get five for the power of
a quarter is now it doesn't have a nice
lady name like square root or cube roots
just like them this is cuter this is
square but we're the parents for you
just say 2 power 4 so we would call this
the fourth root of 5 it's the number
where if you multiply it by itself 4
times you'll get five okay
our five to the power of one over other
both are hundred you can actually go to
your calculator this is my bad times
every day now you can purchase into your
calculator to find out what's going on
I'm going to put in five and then the
power button is right next to the square
button do you see it there right that is
and once you get your little square up
there
that's input in there whatever hundred
okay now before you hit equals I want
you to make the prediction what do you
think it will be higher
okay yeah somebody hit equals and this
is what my calculator tells me do you
get it yeah yes now what does it mean
how does this work
is that what you anticipated here's the
idea this w when you multiply it by
itself it gets a little bit bigger do
you see that seriously if I multiply one
by itself over and over again it
wouldn't change if I multiply a number
that's slightly bigger it will increase
the size every time I do it if you do it
a hundred times they will get big enough
to climb back onto five we would call
this we would call this the 100 root of
five
you take the W multiplied by itself a
hundred times to give you fine so now
I'm gonna stop playing on it I'm going
to generalize if I have five any number
to the power of 1 over in if edit to
I'll get a square root if n is three
I'll get the cube root if n is four or
get the fourth root and so on this is
called the nth root of five that's a bit
of a tongue twister on a right now
because that's literally the way up
there the nth root of five okay
so remember we said we find the ground
zero you don't multiply something times
you have one find a power of 1/2 it's
kind of like halfway to five we do it
here you get hot so what do you think
this would be five to the power of 2/3
[Music]
yeah okay okay so there's a lot of
different ways that I can think about
this there are only two that are
important for you to make it across from
the right mode but then I was like you
want as well I'm going to continue RP
because I know I'm going to run a safe
zone in um two thirds do you agree that
is two times
though Saturday therefore I could write
this in a couple of different ways I can
write it as 5 squared to the power of n
services like you see this is a law that
you've been using already when you've
got brackets you just multiply those
pants together right so that's the cube
root of 25 or alternatively can you fill
this line I'm squaring first and then
I'm doing that powder burn after I'm
going to it a different one to I could
use the power of 1/3 and then square it
so instead of the cube root of 25 I can
have the cube root of 5 squared
they're all the same thing if you go
ahead you go to your calculator touch
this it in fact your calculator even has
I believe a cube root button mine is
under the cube button see go shift and
that we square root sign right if your
shift you'll get the 3 appearing it's
the cube root ok and then you can plug
these numbers in for example
chamber 225 is this she points noted so
you can see that now i interested by the
way the cube root of 25 is really really
small you're surprised by how small it
is but actually it shouldn't be like
surprise me because
what's the cube root of spade 27 the
cube root of 27
it's just a 3 3 times 2 times 3 gives
you 27 well meets a pretty close don't
they write it just not 2 3 just a little
bit so instead of land you know 27 you
land on 25